okay we both won
both boards so we got c4 from magnus now
just time control let me just sort that
out so five minutes and they get three
seconds increment is that right it's
five minutes with a three second
increment
fine okay where's wesley gone oh he's
back
wesley and all right so we've got the
english opening he's going to go for d5
here now you remember danny we were
looking at e4
none of that he breaks in the center the
two have played this opening before
uh and just blitzing their moves out
this was that scavenging setup that you
were talking about previously as well
and i think that's where we're headed
but no f5 this time no f5 no no it's
it's just a
it's just a classical dragon this time
no no scavenging
classical dragon um but
okay queen d i'm trying to remember uh
because i mean
magnus has had this before a very
interesting middle game here now
f5 that's a move that wesley likes
making let's quickly get up to date
with our live position so he's taken on
c6
now that is incredibly ambitious from
magnus very risky because he's weakened
his king side
um i mean mag thing is that bishop
covers the c6 pawn so very difficult to
make anything
i have to say i find that a very
risky decision from magnus to take on c6
that does not appeal to me at all um and
well f4 with and and bringing the queen
down here
rook f2 looks so artificial from magnus
very very passive and black can actually
go bishop a5 bishop b6 id as if that
bishop on e3 isn't careful
so many weaknesses in white's position
also more importantly where is white's
play look at that bishop on d5s
defending the c6 pawn
everything under control more space for
wesley two bishops in the position
i'm loving black hair danny yeah
definitely and this is great
rookie six because you know you want to
be able to play f4
and swing the rook this is a dreadful
position for magnus
i really think that he's not going to be
happy here
well i think with these blitz what
happens is that the players have got no
time for emotion they're so focused on
the position playing it move by move
and danny the hardest thing for them is
always to switch from the rapid format
they've just played four
intense games of rapid to going down to
the wire with the blitz
and really coming and adapting yourself
is key here and look at wesley
he is really just going for it he's
throwing everything at
magnus's king h5 hinting at h4
taking more space uh magnus replying
with knight c4 now the rook on e6 can't
jump to g6 so easily because the e5 pawn
is attacked
wesley says i will eventually bring that
rook into the attack he's gotten the
last piece
off the game to the center really taking
control
the more i see it the more i like it for
wesley yeah definitely
and magnus might be able to push that
bishop back which
could be quite a relief actually um i
you know your idea of before the knight
hit c4
of bishop a5 round to b6 was actually
pretty appealing
um yeah but it looks
still very very promising so that's i
guess
directed against e4
wow i mean this this is extraordinary
i guess magnus would really like to play
bishop f2 and e4 but i doubt whether
he's going to have time for that
so he's trying to get the bishop to g5
two and a half minutes remaining
very tense to middle game here extremely
tense
just look at the pawn f4 i think f4
might be possible
now he does he does put the rook on g6
so he wants to go f4 but
at the right time he first brings the
rook to g6 i think f4 is an idea that
white needs to watch out for
bishop g5 dany that you were pointing
out is also
under control now wow this is risky
magnus just goes for the pawn on
a7 that is very brave
yeah and if if f4 well e3
e3 must be the move but e3
you can't just go aha so
that's really nice danny let's just draw
some arrows and show the problem with
the rook on g2 here
uh you give up this pawn but this rook
on g2 is lost so
magnus counter attacking the rook on g6
with knight to e5
uh what happens if black just moves the
rook away rook to e6
well he's just ditching the exchange and
hoping that he's
got enough play which well he might oh
wow
he's he's trying to hold this pawn on e3
but what is going on here the queen now
attacks
the rook on g6 this is this is wild
stuff
this is wild it's the kind of position
where anyone can make a blunder at any
moment so finally he does move the rook
away
and the rook on g2 is trapped it's got
nowhere to run so black can't pick it up
at any time there's no reason for him to
hurry up with it
i'm guessing magnus is going to put the
bishop back on d4
to to hold the knight on e5
and just ditch that exchange but daddy
he might have to just give up both
uh both rooks but queen f5 so that's how
he's holding
the night
very interesting this one is still
so much in the balance but it does
concern me that this bishop
is rather stranded i wonder whether uh
wesley can
lock it out of the game with c5
how is c5 in this position
i don't know whether we need a little
worried about this bishop on d5 i'm
wondering if i can go knight g6 there
so knight g6 would be a little annoying
so wesley decides to keep the bishop on
d5 a very important piece defend it
attacks the queen so queen h5 comes to
mind
picking that pawn up magnus goes for it
knight g6 queen h8 ideas
in the air that black needs to watch out
for and
wow this is the kind of position it's
just about anything can happen here it's
playing for three results more like
playing for two results either white
wins or black wins
no draws here oh he's taken on e5
queen e5 trade the queens trade the
queens don't get checkmated
but now he'll take the rook and play
rook f2 check and take the e pawn
what is going on there fine because you
still
so queen e5 queen e5 let's just have
some arrows on the board we'll keep up
with the live board
here takes takes and then rook f2 check
to take here i think he's going for it
he's going for it
so queen e5 played wesley having a thing
but he doesn't he doesn't need to take
the rook yet
so what he can do is he can come around
here and take this pawn
if he wants to i don't know if that's
the theme but
yeah but taking here and taking on e2 i
don't see what's wrong with that
he's gone for it he's gone for it he's
going to go for the e pawn
and king g2 rook f2
king g1 because king h3 would be too far
away from the e pawn so he needs to keep
the king
close to black's passer uh what is
happening here can white start pushing
e6 yeah
e6 and then play bishop c5 and hold the
e pawn
and not only hold you're threatening me
at king f8 let's just have some arrows
danny king f8 bishop c5 king e8 rook f1
starts threatening checkmate on f8
wow has magnus turned it round
i think he's incredible yeah yeah i
think he has
now has 45 seconds
that is something else unstoppable this
bond rook f1 and e7 are threats how are
you going to fight this
i think oh that's how he's gonna fight
it
but now rook d eight you've got king
eight seven
yeah that's how he's done it
so but the thing is the rook is kind of
stuck because if it comes to f2 then the
e pawn is on
rook d4 hits the bishop
bishop d6 has to be played because
bishop a3 i'm afraid of some b4 stuff so
bishop d6 here
and then he wants rookie four
wow and then if you lose the e pawn you
lose the game
so i oh now hang on he could play rook
d7 as well
i don't know which is better maybe
i i think rook d7 actually i'll alba
then bishop d6
yeah bishop d6 rookie four rookie four
maybe he wants to hold on with bishop g5
the rookie four bishop g5 saving the e3
pawn
yeah i've just just been just been
told in this position of course after
this
takes no no
check check first yeah yeah check first
check first and then takes and e7
wow all right on our live board rookie
four was played spotting that trick and
after rook e4
he goes c5 blocking that bishop so the
e3 pawn is still alive
and but but this must be better for
white
must be better the a pawn is marching
down the board
because there is there's bishop b8 that
bishop d6 that's kind of annoying this
bishop is trapped up but still
yeah you push it but we might get a
trade of
magnus has to be careful that bishop
isn't trapped
for when when the rook comes round
very strange position right that's what
he's doing he's simplifying
so he he can he can do this wesley
shaking his head he's down to four
seconds he takes paul rook takes rick
picks e3
right unless he's got no time he needs
to make a move
bishop d6 he wants to go king e7 magnus
magnus is in control now
on the clock as well okay he's winning
he can just take here
yeah it's gone this this is winning for
magnus because he he does have an extra
pawn on this side of the board as well
see the last bit of it danny bishop e3
bishop g5 is a big threat on the board
and that is it wesley so resigns there's
no way you can fight that that bishop on
d8 is a dead beast let's jump back to
our live game
both these players wesley starts with
the white pieces and there we have it
i was thinking about e4 by wesley but
clearly he wants to avoid any berlins
and magnus gets a chance to go for his
favorite
line in the queen's gambit decline he
starts with a6
not committing to what he wants to do uh
this is a very very flexible move and
we've seen the world champion go for it
several times yeah he magnus does like
this system with a6 doesn't he
um and it is very solid
so can wesley shake it up in some way
now the chat the chat thinks danny
there's gonna be no come back here
well it's not just here there's going to
be no come back in this quarter finals
it's it's hard hard to bet against
magnus yeah i feel so sorry for arjun
okay well everything very orthodox so
far
nothing yeah nothing new actually this
this i do with bishop f4 also well known
in this position because if
black takes then you know this pawn is
annoying
so uh queen c7 normal response
now you can just drop back with bishop
g3 i personally i think that's
um superior to exchanging on d6 oh there
you go the exchange on d6
commentators curse right once more
um but these were those structures danny
you were looking at earlier and white
often has this idea once the development
is finished to go for a minority attack
on the queen side he can often try and
get these a and b
pawn rolling and if he's able to get a
good b5 in
then it ends up creating weaknesses on
the queen side the other idea that white
can often have is to go shot castle
get that rook on e1 and go e4 very
familiar to the anish game that we saw
yeah but do you know what i think black
is so well set up here
um against the minority attack that i
if white i mean of course white can go
for this but i
i just don't think black has any
particular difficulties against that at
all
um i mean i i'm just wondering
whether wesley should simply castle qui
he's in a must-win situation
i i think an option is to call oh there
you go
commentators curse strikes once more
he castled kingside uh but i think
magnus would be really happy with this
because there's
nothing kind of out out of the ordinary
here
um i mean one thing is when you're so
well set up here is that if white goes
for this
you can actually play b5 here and put
the knight on b6
i mean black is is very well set up to
to blockade there
but there are many responses um but that
that's that's one possible idea
yeah lots of plans here for white as
well as you're mentioning that instead
of a3b4 he could try with
rook b1b4 and go a4 when he gets the
chance black has got this idea going b5
knight b6
planting that knight to c4 but whenever
the knight from d7 moves
very often white's knight from f3 is
able to jump to e5
so yes it does look like a slow position
but
lots of rich ideas and wesley starts
with a3
i do believe that he wants to push that
b4 pawn and it's going to be interesting
to see if
magnus actually goes for b5 after b4
well another planet because there's no
immediate
threat to play b5 uh then he's
magnus is is putting his knight on d6 so
again this is
this we've seen it before this is the
dream square for the night
and then you can play bishop f5 to to
chop off the bishops
and like i said i think magnus is
let me kill the the arrows i think
magnus is
very well set up to deal with this
minority attack so i think he's
absolutely
fine 95 the moment he gets an
opportunity and if white get black white
gets one more move then he can also
start thinking about
f4 here knight d6 as you were mentioning
on the board a really nice spot for the
knight uh
white goes rookie one so taking on e5 is
not a good idea because you trade and go
f4 f5 yeah but again i
i i mean maybe i'm prejudiced because
i'm used to playing these kind of
positions with black but
i feel that with the knight on d6 f4 f5
shouldn't be too much of a problem um
you know there's
f6 to drive away the knight
and e4 is is under control
um magnus has got to be happy here
so far so good i would say for the world
champion
and let's not forget wesley has to win
this game and draw is not enough even
though wesley has got no
problems in his position either but it's
not enough he has to create something
and to create something he needs to
break he needs to either play f4
or play e4 he has to take his chances
i don't see how he's going to improve
his position is it time already to take
a drastic decision for whitetail well
let's let's look at f4 he's played
rookie 2 which looks
hesitant but i just want to have a look
at f4 and see
the kind of thing that you know black
could try against that
um i mean one thing is simply f6
and i think black is
is really well i mean you can see he's
played the rook to e8
he's he's so well set up uh that i don't
think
f4 really helps white at all um if
knight c5 the bishop will drop back to
c8
so instead of that he went rookie to
bishop f5
yep that's the one we've been angling
for for a long time
and now
magnus is having a think is he seriously
considering taking with the g
pawn one are you thinking about knight
e5 that would make a lot more sense
exactly that's what he's he's looking at
just throwing that one in and seeing
whether
he wants this structure or whether he's
going to simply recapture
um i don't know could do this and then
f4
and ah knight g3
wow this is what he's thinking about
tanya that's what he's thinking about
he's thinking about knight e5 here
does he want that well the line that you
pointed out after f1 the fork on g3
uh you would want it but he decides not
to go for it he decides to go
knight f5 here and the point is that you
can't come back with the knight to d3
because of knight d4
so black knee white needs to watch out
for this trick
you can't come back knight d3 because of
knight d4 the rook on e2 was hanging
so he had to go back knight f3 and
magnus's knight on d6 and d7
definitely looking better than the split
knights that we have on a4 and
f3 yeah i mean again it's it's just
a very comfortable position for magnus
um very hard
for white to to make progress here
the e4 well will just lead to
liquidation
yeah this is this is very sound just
doubling on the e file
and no advantage on the clock either
this no
now come on can wesley find something
here
f3 i think that's the only chance but
even if he gets in e4
i don't quite believe it i wonder
whether magnus will play
with f5 himself i don't think he needs
to
but no f5 so keeping things under
control
can't go e4 because don't forget the d4
pawn will be hanging
so magnus stops the idea of e4 with
knight f5 also that g3 square very very
weak there
with moves like h3 f3 you've created
weaknesses
yeah yeah i mean if he has time it'd be
lovely to run that pawn up the board
wouldn't it
i actually like magnus's position even
though wesley's the one who needs to win
here
no i i'm with you all the way uh you
know i would
i would take black here i like it
g4 oh this is desperation danny
game on i think he needs to you know he
needs to do something otherwise magnus
just has control
here but let's see
well knight he i was going to say knight
back to d6 is the safe option
and this is the option where he's he's
playing for the advantage
this is the option that the audience
wants to see this is the option we all
want to see
also do not figure out if black gets
queen c7 queen g3 and that will be
super nasty
yeah um i mean f4 can cut that out of
course
but then you're never getting e4 yeah
that's the good news
um
king two played that means now after
queen c7 you
he can drop the knights he can drop the
knight to f1 and then f5 isn't that
scary
uh maybe yeah i'll play g5
maybe scary g5
[Music]
all right let's see we've got it on the
board by the way it is on the board
magnus starts with f5
uh not queen c not including queen c7
knight f1
in f5 oh
this looks pretty bad yeah now queen c7
comes in you have to fall back with the
knight
this is bad news for uh for wesley
queen c7 queen's queen f4 is is
hits this pawn it looks terrible it's
game over this is
too many weaknesses too many weaknesses
knight f6 94 ideas are there
looks it looks fantastic and look at
white's pieces they're just
all defending no targets on the board
all of black's pieces playing super
actively
magnus now just fully focused trying to
find the finish here
and one gets the feeling that it exists
in this position
yeah knight of knight f6 can be met by
um king e2
uh then knight
knight f6 maybe knight c3
so he first danny pushes that knight
away back to c3
and now he can even think about going
knight b6 knight c4 provoking more
so if that's taken then d4
and look at wesley oh that's he is being
thrown a shocker after shocker
first the sacrifice that got the f4 fork
in and now
knight c5 with d4 coming in this is what
happens when you have an
angry magnus carlson let me let me just
show this one if it takes you play here
here takes here
check and then we take this one
and that looks wonderful for black i
think
basically we're just heading into an end
game um
well with lots of lots of pawns oh hang
on how do we get there
wait a second it's gone it did go like
this
but this is just winning it's over
there's just no way that wesley is
coming back from this position he's upon
down look at white spawn structure
h3 c5 a3 all these pawns are weak
uh only thing white is hoping for is to
get knight e4
knight f6 in and black before getting
greedy
improves his own knight we'll put it to
d5 so that there's no check
on f6 and this is just game over
that that tanya that is super chunky
yeah i do
like well you need to first save the
ropes rook d3 check takes the pawn
knight f6 and now just go king of f8 hit
that truck
uh rook
yeah i okay he's he's he's fighting
but it's not good enough nice move rook
c6 does knight d4
check oh yeah that's sweet
and the c5 pawn is hanging king c8 now
the c5 pawn will fall
right now oh magnus be careful
not so clear so knight c5 rook c6 still
coming in
and magnus for the first time looking
slightly concerned
shaking his head so he's gone passive
with the knight which holds that
he should be okay but wesley is fighting
now come on can wesley do this
still yeah
and this isn't game on again dany this
says game on there's a g
passer black's knight on d8 very passive
wesley cuts off the king a little smile
on his face there
i haven't seen that in a while and he's
still got this trick
takes and rook takes c6 yeah but he can
just come back
knight yeah king d7 that's
that's probably the way to go do you
know what when there are nights on the
board it always gets tricky
oh but now magnus has control he'll take
with check i need total control
total control look at that king knight
and rook now everything's fine white is
never getting g5
in by the way check out the clock times
wesley has just seconds left
[Music]
good move controlling f5
yeah i mean it's it's over magnus is
getting
over the g pawn isn't going anywhere and
the three pawns on the queen side
will decide rook h5 he can start pushing
those spawns already
and wesley knows that it's all done
yeah okay magnus just being
super safe just trading off
okay i think that's it we can call it a
day
that is it and and not only magnus but
levon aronian also drew his second game
against arjun aragasi and
with that qualifies to the semi-finals
uh this one
also uh yeah that's it the cf h5 pawn
falls
and with that p4
what a fight what a fight
[Music]
[Laughter]
and there we have it the two players
after the epic fight relieved magnus
carlsen there just so relieved with this
uh
with this blitz play off because the way
the rapid portion went
today was definitely a setback for him